I did want to move on and talk
specifically about a game that like I
said will be mentioned more next week
we're gonna get into you know other
games were anticipating this year but I
wanted to specifically talk about
battlefront two first rob you and I
played a lot of battle from I reviewed
it I gave it a seven out of ten last
year two years ago sorry 2015 yeah so as
long as it feels but battlefront to
officially announce it has a single
player campaign they're going to
announce more of it at Star Wars
Celebration next week in Orlando from
the 12th to 16th i believe it's taking
place but we want to talk about what we
want from it um Callie seems like you
played a lot about earlier battlefront
games yeah I was a big fan of like the
or I was just really into Star Wars
games in the era when there were a ton
of Star Wars games yeah um yeah and I
also will be attending star wars
celebration oh that's awesome i'm
jealous type guy said one year it's it's
actually like of the conventions I've
been to it's probably the most enjoyable
because it's a pretty you know whether
your star wars fan or not there's
something to be said about seeing like a
multi-generation like in one room where
it's not just a dad and his and his son
or his daughter it's the granddad and
his son and their daughter like you know
I mean like you just see these families
go and the kids are just like so giggidy
just like wow wow it's just a really
cool experience its kind of walk around
it's less stressful than like a comic
con people just sprinting till I get on
their suicides my exclusive merch yeah I
mean I've told you guys before like I
had like I'm a mild panic attack I'd
like last Comic Con trying to get
somewhere with a camera can watch Susan
Suicide Squad panel and everyone's get
me out of here yeah uh but yeah and it's
a very cool event and yeah you should be
really excited as me awesome oh it's
excited talking specifically about
battlefront the remake last year that
dice did sorry 2015 that died stood a
lot of like spectacle felt great as a
star wars game but as a game as a
shooter I didn't really find it to
engrossing it felt a lot of surface and
I got bored really fast if I saw the
planets played all the different
factions it did not
after me whatsoever yeah it felt like um
a dumb down battlefield but with Star
Wars skin to me yeah and then even like
all the modes that they kind of threw in
there again it was it looks great um
like fantastic but it's also as a Star
Wars fan I liked it as a person who
likes video games it wasn't too
thrilling for me um so I guess building
off that and then going back to what we
liked about battlefront one and two from
back in the day on the xbox ps2 game
cube era where they they weren't on give
you um xbox ps2 what do we want to see
in battlefront two cali like what's one
major thing you want this battle front
two from EA and dice to do i mean i'm
really excited about the single-player
honestly I'm I get really anxious about
playing online sometimes I like to have
like if I'm you know if I just want to
like relax or I'm one guy you know I
just wanna play battlefront like by
myself I just want to like experience
some Star Wars maybe have a little like
story stuff or go to a planet that I
really like from the movies I want to be
able to do that on my own time and so
I'm really excited I hope they do
something really meaningful with the
single-player campaign like I'm honestly
so excited for that I know a lot of
people are into multiplayer yeah you
know I just did I totally agree and you
know remembering the first two games
like yeah they're Peters aside looking
at this footage I mean this is we'll
talk about these heroes later but yeah
as far as like the Galactic conquest
mode right where it actually wasn't so
heavy-handed narrative wise but there's
somebody said about like taking over a
whole system and then the galaxy as
either Imperial or the rebellion or like
the CES or the clone yes the clones in
yeah sorry battlefront 2 but yeah no I
mean like the overarching strategy
elements of that right like you know
like having those wait but almost like
ice like a better starfox right ladies
maps like open up like you know I'm
gonna take Tatooine opposed to like a ha
there's some like that like just having
to add that just being able to branch
out and when playing a risk but in a
video game yeah you manage your fleets
as well you manage all they sleep like a
thousand credits yeah imperial star
destroyer risk for context yeah same
here yeah I'm
were the Rings was better that was nice
to play um but that there's a lot about
battlefront the last one that I wish
they could yeah they're just there's a
lot I don't know if you guys want to
keep going yeah I just I don't I didn't
play very much of this game at all like
only a couple of rounds because I like
you guys didn't find the shooting that
exciting but I was just disappointed to
see them cheap in like the characters
and the themes of this world by just
making it a very superficial experience
and just mixing and matching for the
sake of oh my god like you're Darth
Vader biting on Hoth like wow cool dude
i'm i am on a hundred percent the same
page like you think about all the best
Star Wars games like namely like even
this night to go Republic like shadows
damn fire I mean yeah even shadows like
yeah yes like you're you're still
playing something very different
regardless of it being on Hoth like I
was kind of neat how they did tions but
yeah like to vamp on why is Luke in
return of the jedi outfit on Hoth like
it's just these element I don't need
that what I want is to feel if you're
gonna make me and burst sorry immersed
in this world I want to pretend I am my
own guy this is you know cool i'm a
Rodian wherever it is let me feel that I
don't need to see the Emperor doing
barrel rolls with like dude yeah like I
just don't want any of that I want
something new and I think you know ever
since disney body i'm not gonna vamp too
much on that but like you know we talked
about before as far as I there there's
such a drive I feel like that's
misinterpreted of like showing what we
know to be Star Wars like original
trilogy even and I think they won't I'd
really because I know I tries I know
it's really difficult for them to any
for any property to make their own star
wars game without double-checking with
Lucasfilm right like that's such a very
I'm sure like tough thing to do but that
being said I don't need to see you on
solo anymore yeah I don't need to see
these things I want I want something
very fresh um yeah I mean some someone a
major meteor on Twitter had been asking
what we want to see with battlefront 2
and then he said personally I want to
see prequel theme content return I'm
actually oddly enough I'm there with him
because in battlefront to the older one
I really liked so the one thing I don't
like the prequels as movies
but the one thing I do like is reaction
um is the action and the the clone war
oh yeah yeah yeah and like seeing more
variety maybe even like two more
factions you know like the Trade
Federation or the CES Confederacy and
then also the Clone Army that'd be
really cool to see in battlefront so I
could totally get behind having some
Clone Wars themed content yeah
absolutely republic commando I like that
game a lot hell yeah kind of flies on
the radar the other thing gravity rush
the other thing that I and you mentioned
like spaceships early before the shows
if there's one let down that feels like
a nice cop out was the presence of
tokens or power ups on the field where I
mean even you could just I feel like
even bath with one was gone doing that
right where you had to be in the map in
order to spawn into a tank or something
like that there is that lack of joy of
rushing to any kind of vehicle and
hopping in like taking off in an x-wing
no no you just start in the air like
yeah also in that respect where's the
strategy involved if you want if you had
five six friends it's like okay cool
what you don't excuse me two of you guys
get in the air and then I'll get in like
you know an 80 80 and we'll tackle this
field you can't do that yeah you haven't
you have no idea what you're getting to
you just spawn and then hopefully I'll
come across a vehicle token that's
randomly dropped i mean that's just it's
def I'm een you said it before it feels
like a cop-out like it's just like oh
yeah pick up but it's just yeah it takes
away all of the like excitement I mean
basically what you celebrating Yeah
right there with you yeah yeah jumped
into this game and then two hours and I
started losing its luster for sure it
didn't it didn't I want it to be more of
a shooter honestly I think making it you
know giving it the star wars sheen and
paying you know due respects to his
characters I don't even know you could
be r2d2 was this DLC sure okay um what
does that like an EMP blast he just sent
out I think you control it I think it's
a certain mode like actually I'm gonna
defend the bond or something like that
well these are even the deal see like
you know I kind of covered the Scariff
update that was underwhelming for me
again and I think it was just another
excuse
like to look at the property of Star
Wars and make it and make content around
that opposed to the other other way
around and having some kind of creative
drive to make something different no
it's like all right let's do Scariff and
just it's star wars in service of a game
yes it should be the other way I want
dice to take its experience with
battlefield and implement that a little
more here with battlefront 2 but yeah
like how I said the single-player
campaign is the drawing aspect for me
right now because I don't love the
multiplayer the first game yeah cool
yeah so as usual let us know if you're
in the chat right now or if you're gonna
be watching son youtuber gamespot at a
later date let us know what you want
from battlefront 2 like I said next week
later next week there will be more about
it will see again this could be nothing
but like EA and dice are saying it's
their biggest reveal ever but they say
that all the time um but what does that
mean I don't know how do you qualify
that that's that's why i said this could
mean nothing but anyway yeah let's go
big curtain it's like literally
literally physically huge just the
biggest physical what if they just
destroy a planet in real life that would
you be sick yeah like old school like
original Star Wars trailer like they
have no no no it's like battlefront 2
and they're like they're no go dice
itself destroys like Jupiter in real
life three instant Ludo has a planet and
then explode it oh yeah I think what I'm
still excited to umm yeah yeah or they
could just destroy the entire Andromeda
galaxy we won't have to play a game sat
there anymore BAM roasted uh leave your
thoughts below hey we don't if we don't
get what we want a Val front reveal next
week I'm pretty sure we're going a star
wars episode 8 trailer oh yeah they'll
be great and that is something I will
watch many many times you like Star Wars
II ok cool uh like I said let us know
what you want battlefront to thank you
and thank you major meteor for the
question
you